and this is it VW's new cutting-edge
model the RT on is positioned above the
Passat not as a successor to the
full-size luxury Phaeton but to the CC
which in turn is based on the Passat
andre explains of the RT on suspension
has some special features for one it was
optimized for use with 20-inch alloy
rims standard on the RT on our 18-inch
rims but since this is such a design
oriented car he thinks most buyers will
opt for the 20 inches the adaptive
chassis control has also been pepti he
turns out the individual mode to
fine-tune the stiffness using an
infinitely variable slider between sport
at one end and comfort at the other he
personally thinks it works brilliantly
he gets the feedback he wants from the
road but it's never uncomfortable
overcomed is this neat one big family
this test car is powered by the RT ons
top diesel with 176 kilowatts standard
width it is the 4motion all-wheel drive
for a base price in Germany of some 50
1600 euros a highlight for Andre is the
revamped adaptive cruise control not
only does it hold the speed entered and
the distance to the car in front it can
reach Street Science in GPS data and
recognize for instance changes in the
speed limit and it's just the car speed
accordingly it also knows when the cars
entering or leaving a town and helps the
driver avoid getting fine for speeding
because these overlooked a sign that
enhances safety and can even help cut
down on fuel consumption since it
accelerates and breaks more efficiently
that's not really feel if it's sentence
the RT on is available in the accented
sporty Arline variant seen here in the
yellow or the somewhat checkered
elegance version they share the
expressive headlight design with the LED
daytime running lights as part of the
grills chrome-plated cross bars
after the positive residents from the RT
on concept car the production model is
set to be rolled out just one year after
the study's presentation this 5-door
coupe a is now VW showcase for drivers
assistant systems Hungary points out
that while the art he looks fresh
outside there's not that much new on the
inside you can see it's built on the
modular concept most of the interior is
familiar from the Passat
the sat-nav is taken from the facelifted
golf nothing inside the ar-10 is really
surprising the Archaean contains more
technology than the facelifted gulf or
the Passat but it's not exactly
revolutionary it's best described as
another step in the development using
VW's well-known building blocks fund it
but it's hard for Andre to find anything
to criticize as the arty on does a good
job of combining VW's basic values like
good use of interior space with a solid
technological basis and a great body
design rarely seen with this mate but he
adds VW could have kept up that good
work for the interior it seems to him
that the designers lost their confidence
so the art he owns interior doesn't do
justice to its exterior the arty on is
more a timid attempt to expand the
upmarket end of VW's model range after
the Phaeton more or less failed in
Germany but technologically the arty on
is just a better Passat with a new name
[Music]